this is julia manchester from the hill
in washington julia thanks for joining
us today
we're here to talk about the emerson
poll the a news now emerson college the
hill poll
that looks at voting
trends coming up in the uh november
election welcome
thank you for having me
julie let's talk right away about how
biden is doing uh there there are some
poll questions that talk about how he
would perform in a 2024 matchup with
donald trump and with
ron desantis
can you talk a little bit about
those poll questions and tell us about
biden's chances of winning in 2024
well in terms of winning in 2024 i think
the mood is rather bleak for biden um
look i think he's dealing with obviously
inflation we've hit 9.1 percent
inflation today in the us and i think
that's very much showing in this poll
and you also have a lot of democrats in
general who are unhappy with his job
performance as well as um you know other
voters so i think there's a number of
factors the national mood being one of
them that's really dragging
president biden down in this poll and in
other polls
there's a buzz this week in political
conversation after a new york times poll
came out on monday
that poll indicates that 64 percent of
democrats would prefer a new candidate
in 2024
is it realistic to think democrats might
go with another candidate
well there is certainly a lot of buzz
and we've actually seen one progressive
group roots action who's actually
calling on president biden not to run in
2024 seemingly suggesting that they
would want a progressive candidate to
run instead however right now president
biden is saying democrats want him to
run and he and the administration are
adamant that he will run at this point
however we are seeing chatter that we
rarely see with other former that we've
really seen rarely seen with other
former presidents about how you know
what's his political future even though
we're not even to his first midterm
elections so we're really and i know
this is a cliche we are in unprecedented
times there have been a number of
strange things that have happened over
the past six or seven years in u.s
politics so anything could happen at
this point but i would say biden is not
in a great place when it comes to his
approval ratings in the party and
outside the party
there's no recent precedent is there for
a sitting president to be
replaced by another candidate midterm
excuse me after a first term
not that i'm aware of no recent
precedent i mean we saw that president
trump still ran in that election
president obama before him so we really
do see the leaders of these parties
really galvanize their bases galvanize
the party apparatus and that party
apparatus gets behind them and the party
apparatus as of now when we look to the
establishment organizations within the
democratic party whether that's the dnc
the dscc
um the d triple c they're behind
president biden at least publicly i
think what we're seeing is these more
progressive groups within the democratic
party really starting to push back
against the president we've seen that
the progressive movement while they
haven't had that many uh major electoral
victories they are gaining prominence
progressive movement is spreading in the
democratic party to a certain degree so
their voices are getting louder and
they're drawing attention to how they
feel about president biden
back to the emerson poll uh 57 percent
of respondents in in our poll of 2000
people said they disapprove of the job
that biden is doing and 32.5 approve
uh when we dive into that a little bit
and look a little bit closer it shows
that 31 of the people polled who voted
for biden in the in the election now
disapprove of his performance and among
democrats 65 percent approve of the job
biden is doing
lower than the 70 percent found in the
new york times poll where does this
leave democrats with less than four
months until the midterm election
well it doesn't leave them in a good
place and i mean that's very jarring i
would say that would be a jarring sign
for democrats coming in a major swing
state like like nevada
democrats need to win nevada whether
it's at the gubernatorial level the
senate level and the house level there
are a number of major races toss-up
races happening in the state so if the
leader of the democratic party right now
is not looked favorably upon by
democrats i think that could lead to
some serious questions uh as to how big
will uh democratic turnout be in nevada
come november you know will uh
independent voters will democrats even
you know vote for the democratic party
or will they switch the republican party
i think we can definitely say that the
majority of democrats will likely vote
along party lines in the midterms but
what i mean is that we should really
look at those independent or swing
voters in areas like las vegas for
example that could very much decide many
of these elections i think if you are a
vulnerable incumbent like catherine
cortez maska masto steve sisselak susie
lee dina titus you're looking at this
poll and biden's approval ratings and
you're wanting to take a step back from
the president and wanting to you know
focus on your own profile in the state
and your own record in order to really
distance yourself from him
i think that's a really good point a lot
of times you'll see a sitting president
come through a state on an election
swing a campaign swing do you think
that's likely this year
we'll have to see you know i thought it
was notable last week when president
biden traveled to cleveland to ohio and
i would say that ohio is not a swing
state in the same way nevada is ohio
definitely leans more to the right but
the democratic gubernatorial candidate
nan whaley and the democratic senate
candidate congressman tim ryan did not
appear with biden at the event he was
holding for union workers we know that
ohio is a big union state similar to
nevada but
tim ryan and nan whaley are two people
who are huge union advocates and they do
a lot within the union community in ohio
so to see other ohio democratic leaders
come and support biden at this union
event
but not see these two relatively
vulnerable
democratic candidates not appearing with
biden sort of shows you
you know where their head is at and
trying to distance themselves from him
now whaley and ryan and many other
candidates uh you know in similar
positions um whether it's biden or not
said that this was due to a scheduling
conflict so i think biden's going to
have to be very careful about who he
campaigns for and who he doesn't it
depends how he plays in the state
now about half this poll is being
released today and then they're coming
back tomorrow with the second half
first half covers the governor's race
the u.s senate race and these uh
these looks at biden's possibilities in
2024 as well as
uh approval rating for the supreme
court's performance is what sticks out
to you
in in that section of the poll
you know i think in that section of the
poll you have
how biden's running compared to how
incumbents are running notably catherine
cortez masto and steve sisilak he they
are running a few points ahead of him in
nevada whereas biden you know has a
slightly lower approval rating than them
and i think part of the reason for that
is that they have a bit of a distance
from washington obviously senator cortez
masto is in washington quite a bit
however she's still running as a
statewide figure same thing with
governor sisilak joe biden is seen as
the ultimate national democrat so it
makes sense for them to be maybe running
a few points ahead of him a number of
points ahead of him and i think you're
going to see democrats talking about
that when they're talking about how
biden's disapproval ratings or approval
ratings impact their candidates in fact
a lot of democrats working at senate
races have already pointed out to me
that their candidates that they're
working for are actually polling above
biden so i think it goes to show
how much of an albatross really the
former
excuse me the president is around a lot
of these candidates next but they're
going to be talking about how they're
pulling better than
he is i also think it's notable that
sisilak and cortez masto are polling
better than um you know their republican
challengers look i'm sure we will see
those numbers very much narrow as we get
closer to election day or or potentially
change however right now i think this
shows that they have an incumbent
advantage um in a state that's you know
one of the most competitive senate and
gubernatorial states going into november
and it shows how much the party
apparatus is really behind them we know
that the democratic machine is already
pouring money into nevada whether it's
at the senate level the governor's level
or the house level and i think in a way
that's being reflected in this poll
however don't expect these numbers to
remain this wide i think it's very
possible they could narrow as we get
closer to november
you know look democrats are
you know how much freedom unions get in
the state for example we know that the
culinary union is a giant in nevada and
there's a huge union presence especially
in las vegas so i think you could
potentially see
unions being affected you see democrats
talking about that
you see a lot of social issues also
being brought up such as the impact it
could have on the issue of abortion in
nevada we know that abortion is legal in
nevada but um democratic candidates
across the country even in states where
abortion is legal are still trying to
make this a campaign issue so i think
they'll continue to talk about that
and someone like sisilak would talk
about that um you know and i think in
terms of uh government spending how the
economy is run i think you could you
would likely see more of a conservative
figure in a joe lombardo um you know
maybe being a bit more fiscally
conservative when it comes to spending
in the state and in terms of what the
governor is focused on i mean that could
change as well we know that governor
sislek has talked about you know prime
and that issue however someone like joe
lombardo a sheriff is going to probably
have a more a deeper interest in that so
i think those are some of the potential
changes we could see
i want to thank you for your time today
i appreciate it very much
thank you